uranium mining has a long history in
Native American lands
during the Cold War uranium dug from
Navajo land powered U.S nuclear weapons
Navajo miners were exposed to deadly
radiation they were sick it made their
families sick
and you know there wasn't a lot of good
information provided to people so they
could protect themselves and so there's
really a horrible
um
Legacy relative to uranium
hundreds of radioactive waste dumps
still Scar the reservation
President Joe Biden's creation of a new
National Monument was meant in part to
ban future uranium mining on tribal
lands
but not completely
this is the Pinon Plains uranium mine
owned by Energy Fuels Corporation
it's legally exempt from removal even
though it's in the new monument opinion
plain mind does exist it still will
continue to exist in theory it's been
told that it was grandfathered in
beginning in 2016 Mine Workers breached
an upper layer of groundwater at the
site and have been pumping out
contaminated water ever since right now
there's thousands and thousands of
gallons of water that is viewing from
the mine and lays within a pond outside
of the actual mine there's no way of
them actually mitigating the water at
this point
for the Havasupai tribe in Grand Canyon
groundwater contamination is a lethal
threat I worry about the most for the
water that runs in my Village
the water that sustains my
smity I worry that that water will
either dry up or be contaminated forever
which will then cease the history of my
people
energy fuel says it has put
state-of-the-art environmental controls
and groundwater protection in place but
environmentalists warn that uranium wine
waste can remain dangerously radioactive
for thousands of years
if indeed the mine
contaminates the lower aquifer
there's really no way to clean it up a
deadly Legacy and a continuing Danger
Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Coconino County
Arizona